Später an diesem Tag,
als das Team hier am
Krankenbett war, war der Präsident
aus dem Bett aufgestanden und hatte sich nur mit leichten Symptomen in der Wohnung bewegt,
trotzdem waren sich alle einig, dass die beste
Vorgehensweise darin bestand, zu Walter
Reed zu gehen,
um jetzt eine gründlichere Überwachung zu erhalten
i  Ich möchte Dr. Dooley einladen, den
aktuellen Plan zu besprechen.
Vielen Dank, Dr. Conley. Ähm, bevor ich mit einem
kurzen klinischen Update zum
Zustand
des Präsidenten beginne.  disziplinäres
multi-institutionelles Team von klinischen
Fachleuten hinter mir
und was für eine Ehre es ist, den
Präsidenten hier im Walter Reed National
Military Medical Center zu betreuen.
Bezüglich seines klinischen Zustands
verbessert sich der Patient weiter, er ist
seit Freitagmorgen fieberfrei,
seine Vitalzeichen sind
aus pulmonaler sicht stabil bleibt er
heute morgen an raumluft
und klagt nicht über
kurzatmigkeit oder andere signifikante r  Atemwegsbeschwerden
Er geht selbst herum
, ohne Einschränkungen oder Behinderungen im Krankenhaus des Weißen Hauses.
Unsere kontinuierliche Überwachung seiner
Herz-, Leber- und Nierenfunktion
zeigt weiterhin normale Befunde
oder sich verbessernde Befunde,
und ich übergebe es jetzt an Dr.
Garibaldi
von Johns Hopkins an  Sprechen Sie über unsere
Therapeutika und noch einmal über
unseren Plan für den Tag.
Vielen Dank, Dr. Dooley, und ich wollte nur noch
einmal wiederholen, was für eine Ehre und ein
Privileg es ist, sich um den Präsidenten zu kümmern
, aber Teil eines so
talentierten und multidisziplinären Teams
hier zu sein
bei walter reed, ähm, der Präsident hat
gestern Abend seine zweite
Dosis Remdessevier abgeschlossen, ähm,
er hat diese Infusion gut vertragen,
wir haben sie auf mögliche Nebenwirkungen überwacht,
und er hatte keine, von denen wir sagen können, dass seine
Leber- und Nierenfunktion
normal geblieben ist,
ähm und  Wir planen weiterhin einen
fünftägigen Rem-Earning-Kurs als
Reaktion auf vorübergehend niedrige
Sauerstoffwerte als Dr.
Conley  hat besprochen, dass wir eine
Dexamethason-Therapie eingeleitet haben,
und er hat gestern seine erste Dosis davon erhalten,
und unser Plan ist,
dass
er sich bis auf Weiteres gut fühlt, er war wach, und
unser Plan für heute ist, dass
er essen und trinken
soll  so viel wie möglich aus dem Bett,
um mobil zu sein,
und wenn er weiterhin so gut aussieht und sich
so fühlt wie heute, hoffen
wir, dass wir bereits morgen eine Entlassung
ins Weiße Haus planen können, wo er
seine Behandlung fortsetzen kann  vielen dank
und ich wende mich an dr. connelly für alle
fragen,
einen moment bitte, der
präsident wollte, dass ich ihm mitteile, wie stolz
er auf die gruppe ist,
was für eine ehre es für ihn ist
, seine pflege hier bei walter reed zu erhalten,
umgeben von solchen  unglaubliches talent
akademische leiter
abteilungsleiter international
renommierte forscher und
kliniker einschließlich der unterstützung von dr
Und
damit nehme ich Ihre Frage an,
Sie sagten, dass es zwei Fälle gab, in
denen er Sauerstoffabfälle hatte. Können Sie
uns durch den zweiten führen, und
ich habe danach eine Frage an den Lungenspezialisten.
Sicher, ja,
ja, gestern, äh, gab es  Eine weitere
Episode, in der er um
etwa 93 Prozent gesunken ist, ähm, er fühlt sich nie kurzatmig, ähm,
wir haben es gesehen und es ist wieder hochgekommen
, wie ich sagte, wir bewerten all dies
und geben Ihnen die Zeitleiste, in der er sich
im Krankheitsverlauf
befindet  Wir wussten, dass wir versuchten, alles zu maximieren,
was wir für ihn tun konnten,
und
wir diskutierten, ob wir überhaupt damit anfangen würden, äh,
Dexa-
Dexamethason, und wir entschieden, dass in
diesem Fall
die potenziellen Vorteile zu Beginn des
Kurses wahrscheinlich alle Risiken zu
diesem
Zeitpunkt überwogen  Sie haben ihm gestern eine zweite Runde
zusätzlichen Sauerstoffs gegeben,
äh, ich müsste, ich müsste mich mit
dem Pflegepersonal erkundigen
der
einzige Ochse  Ygen, das ich bestellt
habe, das wir zur Verfügung gestellt haben, war äh dieser
Freitagmorgen anfangs
wie spät war das gestern äh
gestern was war gestern
Sie sagten die zweite Instanz zweite
Vorfälle oh es war im Laufe
des Tages ja
gestern Morgen wie ist der
aktuelle
äh Blutsauerstoff des Präsidenten  Ebene, das ist meine erste
Frage an Sie, Dr. Conley
98, und was zeigen die Röntgenbilder
und CT-Scans, gibt es Anzeichen
einer Lungenentzündung, gibt es Anzeichen einer Lungenbeteiligung
oder irgendeiner Schädigung der Lunge, ja, also
verfolgen wir all das,
ähm, es gibt einige  erwartete Befunde, aber
nichts von äh,
irgendwelchen größeren klinischen Bedenken bei den aktuellen
Nachrichten, die
niemand hier hat